and to talk about that we're happy to be
joined in the studio by the Ukrainian
foreign minister pavlo klimkin welcome
to the show thanks very much for being
with us good morning it's a pleasure to
be there um you know the first question
has to be how much is Ukraine willing to
make compromises to make the ceasefire
agreement work okay
compromises is important of terminology
for me the opponent of substance is the
Russians willingness to deliver or Minsk
agreements and Minsk agreements are in
essence a kind of peace plan so if you
like to go towards peace what what do
you do normally you stop shooting you
let the oil sea to control the territory
you let the OEC to control pooling out
of forces you let the OSE to control the
part of the border where we've been
getting the whole inflow of weapons of
Russian regular troops and you start
talking about free and fair elections
how would you make in Donbass free and
fair elections but the Russians are
saying that they are in fact upholding
the Minsk agreements that they're the
ones that are keeping everything going
okay just to give you a couple of
examples we have in Dumba's now
2010 and time what vehicles we have the
whole lot of weapons
can we start preparing for elections
having the whole lot of weapons and
dauntless heavens a continuous inflow
through the Ukrainian Russian border you
know the batch which we don't have under
our control and if we have 50 60 70
shellings from prohibited weapons so is
it a kind of real launch for any kind of
effect you start mr. foreign minister
the Kremlin though is saying that they
have very limited influence in the
Donbass over the Ukrainian separatists
look it's a joke there are no people who
are independent from Russian military
the whole situations there is steered
from Rostov from Russia by Russian
militaries and who isn't
is Russian Special Forces yeah and
Russian special agencies it's even in
the sense of currency the Russians have
been trying to eject more Russian ruble
I'm do my own dumb but these are
informal talks going on right now yeah
here in Germany is there a way the
channels can be open to talk to the
Russians for the Ukrainians and the
Russians to talk and and hammer these
things out behind the scenes look
firstly we have Normandy format we have
to stick to Minsk and we have to stick
to Normandy format because the Germans
in the French who have been acting with
the clear mandate by the European Union
are really important place and we've
been enjoying continuous support by the
Germans and the French but here you see
Russia clearly playing on time not
trying to deliver on everything but
simply waiting for more destabilization
in Ukraine in train actively to
destabilize situation waiting for future
elections here in Europe you know
somehow believing that it would also
disturb you lies situation here and
maybe playing for US election to come so
it's a kind of conundrum and we need
Russia to deliver all means because of
that sanctions are important so the
deity is important and political
pressure it is very important mr.
foreign minister wouldn't away forward
be perhaps to declare autonomy and then
have elections allow autonomy for the
government Korea Kiev to allow the
Russian separatists in this part of
Ukraine first have autonomy and then we
have the elections what what is autonomy
II in this sense if you have Russia
fully control and situation in Donbass
and if we give autonomy like the
Russians believe it's the way forward
and for the for Russia is the Rachel's
federalization Choate's weakening up and
fragment in Ukraine is just about
legitimizing the Russian Protectorate
now in Dumba's and after that
strategy is to put to push this
Protectorate back into Ukraine is a kind
of trial course
what's the Ukrainian strategy that
Ukrainian strategy is to deliver on
Minsk and it's easy if you are ready to
deliver on means is stop shelling to
give control for the situation for the
OEC for the special monitoring mission
and for the amp'd or AC police mission
to control the situation to get russian
weapon out of Dumba's and to start
preparing for free and fair elections ok
do you think the separatists would go
along with that is their chance
look it's just about Russia there are no
any kind of independent people in
Donbass independent from Russia it's all
about Russian steering Zam ok one
disconcerting development is the
announcement by President Petro
poroshenko that he's preparing were
willing to introduce martial law and a
new wave of military mobilization don't
you think that that would further
escalate the situation look the
president clearly said if the situation
gonna substantial reversal there there
could be consideration about is that
huge introduced and marshal or about
introducing other measures so far we
need to fully commit ourselves she sees
file to pressure Russia to deliver means
and to get the OSCE on the ground and
you get the OSCE and they mean special
monitoring mission and and police
mission on the ground and look just
imagine we have 2,000 tanks and armored
vehicles we need to put this weaponry
and the clear control the better way
would be to push it back because it's
all Russian weapon let's get back to
Russia and let's have free and fair
elections but under international
control mister pavlo klimkin foreign
minister of ukraine thank you so very
much for your time for being with us
today thanks a lot it was a pleasure